thank you for joining us and we're going
to be talking about that this evening
and working our way through it is based
here at Hillsdale College
he is our lecturer and research fellow
for the college here in Washington DC
where he teaches undergraduates and will
be teaching in our Graduate School of
Government we're getting ready to start
here very soon before that he was a
deputy assistant to the president United
States working on national security and
he previously had other political and
corporate roles he's also a senior
fellow with the Claremont Institute our
good friends out in California his works
have appeared in The Wall Street Journal
Washington Post and Worth's other places
and he is a regular on Fox the original
essay the flight 93 election appeared in
the Claremont Review of Books on
September 5th 2016 this book we have
here is actually made of three essays
that original essay a second essay which
also appeared after the first replying
to critics and a new essay along s a the
Restatement on flight 93 assuming a new
essay which is a pre statement a prequel
if you will although I add that it's a
good prequel not like the Phantom mentis
for all those Star Wars fans so what I'd
like to is talk about all of those
because they're all interesting they're
in an especially interesting and spend a
lot of time on the the pre statement the
additional work he's done laying out his
opening to set up that that up but I'd
like to first talk about the original
flight 93 election essay and Michael
begin by welcome you here but also tell
us about that there's a lot of great
backstory to that original essay right
it goes way back in a sense that I think
like every well I'll speak only for
myself when Donald Trump announced that
he was running for president in June of
2015 I did not take it seriously because
it would the third time he was running
in both of the previous two occasions
never got into a primary he never was
around when a single vote was cast he
seemed to be around in the early stages
made a lot of noise made his point and
ducked out and the purpose seemed to be
publicity so I didn't take it at all
seriously and he kept saying publicly
you know no I'm in it for real this time
I'm here to win and I have an agenda and
you need to take it seriously and as the
months wore on and I listened I thought
all right I'll try to take it seriously
and I began to think actually your
program your platform makes more sense
to me it's more appealing to me than the
other in the field and so now that's
that I got to say that's it was an
unorthodox position that's the nice way
to put it but also with somebody from
sort of my background how'd it be worked
for a lot of conventional or at least
more conventional Republicans with a you
know somebody from a more traditional
conservative background and it's safe to
say Matt and I had basically the same
education this was not a popular
position not merely among mainstream
Republicans but among people who were
trained the way we were trained so I
asked for permission or I asked if the
Claremont Review of Books which was my
sort of home base I was in the corporate
world at the time but I wrote for the
Claremont Review once or twice a year
asked if they would be interested in a
piece defending Trump you know as the
best Republican candidate and this is
before Iowa before any vote was cast and
they said Oh we'd love to have that and
so I wrote it spent a lot of time on it
sent it to many friends and so on for
critique that I went through and sent it
in usually the CRB when they get or
anybody usually when they get something
that tell you pretty quick no or yes
this took about three weeks and the
answer was no and I said well in a way
you commissioned this so long story I
was ticked off and somebody who I didn't
know particularly well but I knew a
little bit had written a great piece for
the Weekly Standard now defunct but in
September of 2015
called traitor to his class it was an
analysis of trumpet grabbed my attention
and it turns out that we had some mutual
friends in common then he wrote a
follow-up piece also for the standard on
managerialism and how it explains Trump
and it was very serious take out
teeing off of the famous James Burnham
book from I can remember the date but
sometime in the 50s called the
managerial revolution and the standard
turned that down I just happened to be
at a dinner a very small dinner with
this guy and I'm complaining that you
know my friends turned down my piece and
you say yeah well my friends turn down
my piece and that's in the media
terrible and so our answer his answer
really I didn't think he was serious was
well just gonna start a blogging and
take them all down and so he started it
I went home that night thinking that was
a fun dinner now I have to get up and go
back to my real life and instead I woke
up I checked my computer before I leave
the house and it says you have been
invited to contribute to the Journal of
American greatness what does that mean
he had started he had stayed up all
night he'd set up the blog and he gave
me the pen he's in a few of us he's like
we're gonna actually do this okay so we
made the anchor Pete two pieces of the
Journal of American greatness my
rejected thing in his rejected thing and
then we wish took off from there and it
took a while people started to notice it
I've Ken Masucci who was supposed to be
here maybe he's there
okay that's there Ken was one of the
very first to notice it and started to
write about it power line guys found it
started writing about it but then what
really happened oon of 2016 we started
this in February of 2016
Peggy Noonan wrote a whole column about
it in the Wall Street Journal which
caused some of us not so much me I'm
just saying but some of us to freak out
and think this has gotten too far and so
the plug was pulled and I thought all
right well that's that I won't do this
anymore
but but there you were also writing
under pseudonym yeah all of that was two
tall weeds yes we each we each two we
each chose a Roman name and by the way
let me just say I'm not gonna go into
this in any detail so now because it
takes too long but if you ever want to
publish a book that will allow you 4,200
words to explain exactly why you chose
the pseudonym you chose you only can do
it with encounter dates nobody else will
let you get away with that they did so
it's all there anyway we all had a Roman
name you know mine was Decius or Deki
asst one of the most Plautus in other
words you know a comedian one of them
who is particularly hard over on the
question of the Iraq war chose lucullus
who was the Roman
of Mesopotamia so there's a backstory to
each to each one of the Roma names so a
couple of months go by and I vowed I'm
never gonna do that again because I kind
of risk a lot and it was stupid and I
got away with it so I should move on and
whatever for whatever reason I decided
no I can't move on I've got a I got to
just say something else because I
remember the CRB sent me a note saying
well we're gonna do all this election
coverage do you want to write some
election I said that kind of would but I
also want to remain employed so maybe I
shouldn't then I just did it anyway I
pointed this out when I was at the
Manhattan Institute I got pointed out
here I think it should be recorded for
posterity that piece was written I say
in the book in two days what I don't add
is it was written in Santa Cruz
California which if any of you know is
one of the most left-wing hippy towns in
the Western world so I find that oddly
appropriate anyway I wrote it and I gave
it to my wife and I said what do you
think and by the way you have veto over
this because you know she relies on my
income and if something bad happens then
you know the bad would befall the family
not just me and if you want me not to do
this I won't do it and that's that don't
worry about it and she said do it okay
so I sent it in and I didn't really
think anybody would care because first
of all have a pseudonym right right I
read things I think we all do you look
at the byline first oh I know that guy
like that guy I'm gonna read that if you
somebody that you either know you think
isn't that great or you don't know who
it is you're much less likely to read it
if it's an obviously made-up name you're
probably just as whatever and or you
would recognize the name and go how this
is from the Journal of American
greatness guy Wow I liked that and then
they'd read the piece and get
disappointed although they're you use
the extended ideal my name they made me
do that for some reason kinda why okay
well the full room and the full Roman
name I thought people who actually
remember jag would be really let down
because they'd say you didn't say
anything you didn't already say on jag
and the only reason I'm reading this is
cuz I remember that name and so I
thought this isn't this is gonna go
nowhere no he's gonna care and well this
came out on Labor Day which was a Monday
and nothing happened and then Tuesday
and nothing happened and on Wednesday I
happened to be working from home
through the firm's VPN and as in my
little home office the door closed
really working on work work and door
opens it's my wife you know about 10
after 12:00 12:15 this is do you want
the good news or the bad news is that I
said I always want the bad news first so
what is it said rush limbaugh is reading
it on the air right now it's the good
news it's preempted in New York by a
Mets game all right and then I thought
for a second Venn diagram senior
leadership of my firm rush limbaugh
listeners I'm gonna be okay and of
course you know I was okay for a while a
lot of people attacked the p-side wrote
a follow up called the Restatement on
flight 93 I just included you the one
thing by the way I regret about this
book which I only thought of of course
in my you know great genius and
foresight is why didn't I include the
original piece that got this whole
kicked off in the first place but I
didn't and by the time I thought of it
though he's way too late the print tree
it's really you'd spent too much time
explaining your student the printers had
run so I ended up in the Trump
administration I was there for about
fourteen months I've been here since I
left the Trump administration and it was
Roger Kimball the publisher of encounter
books the editor of New Criterion who
came to me and said I love that essay I
want to republish it and I said okay I'd
be happy to do that but if you're gonna
republish it then we should do the
Restatement to which I I kind of always
like better in a way but leave that out
and he says and you have to add some new
material at the front I thought well
that's actually a good opportunity
because the the criticisms that I
address in the Restatement which was
published only eight days after the
flight 93 election were all the
criticisms that came in these sort of
immediate online so let's let's do a
brief statement what the original essay
was cuz I think the context of it and
what you were trying to do is important
and and this this is how it starts 2016
is a flight 93 election
charge the cockpit or you die you may
die anyway you are the leader of your
party may make it into the cockpit and
not know how to fly or land the plane
there are no guarantees except one if
you don't try death is certain to
compound the matter to compound the
metaphor a Hillary Clinton presidency is
Russian roulette
with a semi-auto with Trump at least you
can spin the cylinder and take your
chances what what well what was your I
mean there's a there's an clearly an
urgency to your essay how we said what
was the point you wanted to make you
need to vote for this man or we're going
to lose everything
no I and I know I really did well
there's clearly the binary choice
argument but there's there's a deeper
sense there's more at stake here than
just this election that there was a
trend that I saw going on I mean
depending on how you want to define it
if you want to stretch it out maximally
you could say 125 years since the dawn
of the original Progressive Era you
could date it from the 60s but there's a
clear trend and I want to refer to John
Marini who the last time I was up on
this stage I was here with him he was
definitely an inspiration for this in in
more ways than one sort of creeping
administrative state rule had 8 years of
Obama been followed by eight years of
Hillary and I really didn't have any
doubt that it would be a it seems
preposterous to think that with all the
advantages of incumbency with all of
these structural advantages that
Democratic and sort of big government
administrative state presidents he's had
it seemed idiotic to think that she
might be the first president to lose a
reelection campaign since 1992 so I
thought we were gonna get 8 followed by
8 all pointing in the same direction
which would lead to us kind of cementing
of administrative state control as far
as the eye could see that traditional
Republican whether you want to
capitalize the word or leave it
lowercase would not be able to overcome
but there's there was also a certain
frustration shall we say with
conservatism the the push back against
that you say this in your new
introduction in 2016 I judge the modes
and orders of
my time and especially of conservatism
to be exhausted and imprisoned with an
inflexible institutional and
intellectual Authority yes explain what
you mean by that
I guess I meant a couple of things some
of them not very nice but I don't think
therefore inaccurate well I say
Authority right so on one level
conservatism had become about a policy
which doesn't sound crazy why shouldn't
it be but it became solely about policy
so it began to see policies that it
always seemed to me to be means to ends
it began to see them as ends right and
and you know one of the ways that I
found myself set apart or alienated or
whatever you want to say was I thought
well I learned all this great stuff from
my teachers our teachers and from the
books that we studied and I actually
haven't repudiated in any of that I
don't actually think any of that is
wrong I think it's being misapplied
right now so what I saw was a
conservatism that said well if you
understand the founding in a certain way
you understand the Federalists in or
Locke or Aristotle in a certain way then
you must be for this set of policies and
nothing can ever change and Trump is bad
because he questions free trade he wants
to secure the border and he and he won't
he worries about the impacts of
continued immigration mass immigration
illegal immigration and he really
wonders you know he's really harsh on
dumb foreign policy or millennion he
right in the direction and I thought
excuse me
so conservatism would say we trace all
that to these basic first principles and
if you agree with us you're a bad person
and you're not conservative I thought I
can question everything you just said
without stepping one millimeter off of
the same continent intellectual
continent that I've been on my whole
life so some one of us has got a long
right either you don't understand this
stuff the right way or I don't and I
don't think it's me but even if it is
you know we shouldn't we should have an
argument about it and I believe that to
this day I mean I've heard lots of
conservatives say oh you know you guys
meaning you know you people who study
the founding who study Lincoln who
studied political philosophy you've gone
totally astray because if you were true
to your principles you couldn't possibly
support Trump I didn't agree with that
then and I certainly don't agree with
that now yeah it was a part of it
yeah there's some way in which though I
mean our teachers Harry Jaffa in
particular always argued and pointed out
that there was something intellectually
about modern and conservatism that
wasn't quite right which we get more
into but of late it's there's a way in
which the 2016 election kind of pulled
back a curtain if you will and show that
it's also very kind of doctrinal and and
stiff and incapable of making arguments
well look I identified I don't think
this is particularly insightful but I
identified early on you know Trump's big
three where immigration trade and
foreign policy or war immigration was
where I first began to make my break
with traditional conservatism and I saw
the Republican Party and the think tanks
for lack of a better term drift more and
more into an inflexible kind of Chamber
of Commerce position trade was harder
for me because I had never really
studied it I just took for granted the
conservative position that free trade is
better because it produces more and a
comparative advantage and you've heard
all the arguments Trump forced so my
initial reaction to Trump was well he's
bad on trade but he's good on
immigration and then my my other the on
task to the third you know I was in the
Bush administration the second Bush
administration 43 and I was around for
Afghanistan and Iraq and actually you
know didn't have anything to do with
policy really but I helped make a public
case for those things and I watched them
not work the way that public case said
that they would and so it you know
beginning in sort of the mid and
certainly by the late 2000s I have come
to a point where I had to just say
forthrightly this was a mistake we blew
it you know America made a mistake the
Bush administration made a mistake and
conservatism or at least a large part of
it hardened itself into a kind of
defensive position where any questioning
of the wisdom of the Iraq war was
unacceptable and was supposed to make
you unelectable it was supposed to be
you know make you a cat act what am i
what's the the Greek word I'm looking
for ostracized right a self ostracized
from the Republican Party and meanwhile
Trump attacks at forthrightly against
essential
let's say 15 candidates who wanted to
defend well no Paul didn't then Cruz was
lukewarm but everybody else says no this
is a sacrosanct Republican position you
can't be against it you know how many
times did we see in the 2015-16 cycle
I'm over and over again someone would
say he's finally done it now
well that's it he said that it's right
it's over right he's done he's toast he
can't win the nomination now over and
over but that was one of the the basis
for it was Oh
in the South Carolina primary he came
out against the Iraq war well that's the
end for him and instead it boosted him
so I was I was very receptive to that
the one that I held back on was trade is
I hadn't thought about it and I always
thought that the Republican argument was
the right argument or the think tank
argument was the right argument so
instead what I did one night stayed up
very late I can't believe I got to work
the next day but I think I did just
reading three three things I mean I read
the whole books but I looked in the
index and the passages I read Smith I
read Ricardo and I went back to the
politics I lived for some place where it
was said that free trade is a moral
principle or that there's some aspect of
virtue or the good it's involved not
merely an instrumental or means to
prosperity but could find nothing and in
fact could find many instances of Smith
saying the opposite right talking about
the virtues of it in societies or in
economies that are roughly equal but you
know always saying you have to put the
national interest first and things like
this and that just can you know I
thought to myself when I kind of got up
the next day and went to work and had a
pot of coffee I thought I learned
something from Donald Trump Wow right
right he was right and I was wrong and
he forced me to go think it through and
so now like now what do you do I mean
then after that it becomes impossible to
take seriously the notion that he's just
a TV star that there's he's not serious
that he has no ideas and it kind of
opened a lot of doors for me personally
there right okay so your of your critics
of which there were lots some one of the
criticisms was that the original essay
was didn't make a positive argument yeah
as you as you point out all nightmare
and no dream
yeah I mean it made up look I will
defend myself on that to this extent it
made a positive argument isn't it does
say it's better not to step off a cliff
than to step off now that's nothing the
most positive argument one could make
one can talk about what was a relative
positive one builds at the top of the
cliff and I didn't do that but it's not
because I didn't have that I just it was
a it wasn't exhortation in writing right
no I know that
two weeks are sorry two months before an
election and I was telling people you
know this is what I think the stakes are
I will note too that people talked about
it you know there was a lot of criticism
that is very dark and that it was it was
X or ting people to do dangerous
reckless things to which I said and will
say again and I think I said more than
once in the in the book like really the
dangerous reckless crazy psycho thing
I'm telling everybody to do is wait wait
we have to have a dramatic pause vote
and this from you know that I'm supposed
to be anti-democratic and authoritarian
but what all I'm saying to you is vote
now I am telling you I think you ought
to vote one way rather than the other
way but every all political journalism
in a democracy does that right all right
of course right right of course he
doesn't but one of the reasons why you
added this pre statement because I
remember we talked about it when you're
working right and at length I made this
pre statement was to kind of somewhat
fill that void and you made it a pre
statement as opposed to a postscript
because really these are ideas that pre
you know predate in actuality the the
later statement right and so I want to
walk through that somewhat it's its
majority tooth lot of is about what you
call the American solution yeah and then
the other chunk of it is really about
the increasing radicalization and your
concerns about the left and liberalism
so let's do the first thing it has nice
well there's a little beginning and then
it has nine sections as I recall I put
it first I use this fancy phrase just to
try to fool people into thinking I'm
smart I said because of its ontological
priority right which I don't think I
used inaccurate
but it is kind of you know it's just
kind of a terms wait does it does start
with the section on political and moral
epistemology no that sounds very - I got
a little criticism for that people's
like nobody cares about this get to the
point I said no this is actually
important and it's not a long section um
and it's important because part of the
reason I think not just conservatism but
all political thought itself got into a
ditch is because we've forgotten the
simple answers to the question of how do
we know what we think we know about
political and moral things right and I
recapitulate this theme later on when I
talk about progressivism and the
dominance of modern science right modern
science can't answer any of those
questions it can't tell you why the good
is the good it can't tell you why
Liberty is better than slavery it can't
tell you you know why morality is better
than immoral it can't even establish for
you that morality exists that can only
be established dialectically on the
basis of a kind of classical
understanding of human nature and the
virtues and so and it's I try to do this
in the simplest shortest way possible
and I do say at the beginning of the pre
statement that you know this is not a
philosophic treatise you can't walk away
from this book and think well I learned
the great tradition right the only way
to learn the great tradition is you got
to just sit down and spend years reading
I get to go to Hillsdale yeah you go to
Hillsdale go to Hill sell for undergrad
and then go on to grad school and and by
the time you're done with that you
probably have learned the great
tradition so but you do point out that
the very beginning that in short
everyone needs a theory of justice the
left has one the right thinks it has one
but it doesn't right the right oh there
is a connection here to this right this
immediate question the right substituted
it's theory of justice or it allowed
policy to become a theory of justice and
then it forgot the underlying theory so
I first tried to say look moral and
political political epistemology as a
how do we know what we know how do we
know what we think we know about
morality because you can't see it you
can't measure it you know the electron
microscope or any aspect of the
scientific method is of no use in this
but my point is you don't need any of
that okay you can still know moral
things without any of that and it's not
as complicated as we've made it out to
be and then I move on to
I forgotten the way I titled it with
this the human nature your lie your life
in the good good life right so first we
can establish how we think we know what
we know about morality then we have to
ask you know what is the content of
morality of political morality and
personal morality right so mere life in
the good life you have to have both but
you also have to make the distinction
mere life on its own in other words just
survival I think any moral thinker
ancient or modern religious or secular
would say is insufficient right you have
mere life is required for the good life
but it doesn't it is not itself the good
life and it on itself without the good
life there's something kind of debased
about it right not what human beings
right and and even begin going down this
path would take which takes more is to
recognize how we bereft our current
political conversation is of those
various terms and that the left has its
own through your justice light larger
because they've given up and all that
and it's just yeah whatever the next
darn thing is but the Conservatives
there they don't take the end of those
things seriously well I think they think
they know but they don't really know and
the worse I think they don't know that
they don't know so the third section IRA
do remember is called the American
solution writes to say the political
problem in a sense is how do you come up
with the political solution in a given
circumstance forgiven people that both
promotes mere life and promotes the good
life with the understanding that
government can't deliver the good life
right and if you're asking government to
deliver the good life you're at it see
that's a essentially utopian project
that can't be realized what it can do is
create conditions for it it can help it
you couldn't help encourage and help it
flourish but it had it government has to
be a sort of mixture of activism and
pacifism that will always differ with
the circumstances but if you're asking
it to say well you're just simply going
to deliver or create this you're gonna
be let down every time or much worse the
government's just going to do all kinds
of things that it shouldn't be doing
it'll become tyrannical so how do they
you know this is a perennial problem you
can solve it one way in the ancient
world you could solve it another way in
the medieval world depending on where
you are what you know what circumstances
you're dealing
with how did the American founder I
solve it and I lay that out I think in a
fairly succinct form it's a lot of that
is taken from a review that I wrote of
Tom West's a Hillsdale professor I note
his book called the political theory of
the American Founding which came out in
October of 2017
I reviewed the book very
enthusiastically because I loved it I
even loved West right part of that is
unlovable as he tries to be I love ever
since off-the-record so you would only
them but and then the second the section
following that is called the scope and
limits now this is really good go ahead
I want to get into this in some extent
because this is important for the
conservatives because in and I in a way
I have to blame
maybe I'll blame only myself but I'm
implicitly blaming some other people
from my school but I won't name any of
them right we made we contributed to
this problem in that we taught a version
of the truth of what the founders
believed and what Abraham Lincoln
believed and we made it easy for people
to say oh I went and I took a one-week
seminar and I read the Declaration of
Independence and I read the Gettysburg
Address and I read certain and I figured
it all I know I know what it means and
that's all there is to it and so you
know it's we should go back and advocate
tax cuts right and I thought no it's
more complicated than that and in fact
you know the American solution as
beautiful as it is as true as it is has
is subject to practical limits and I try
to lay out with the right much in read
section and and which is a inherit in
the project itself yeah and that's part
of the new time okay so the first one
you have is men are equal only in
obsessing equally the same natural right
right so this is this is a common
criticism I don't know how common it is
but it's at least out there that well
you know that particular school
I mean look we're in we're in Hillsdale
College right now we're in a room with
the founding documents up above us is a
I don't know I don't know if I said that
it is the Constitution okay but it would
have been in the same room so it could
be either one except that George
Washington is there and he would not
have been there for the Declaration of
Independence because he was out in the
field right so people say well I learned
this I sort of learned what the the
principle is I learn what equality isn't
so
the the there's a left-wing critique of
that which says oh you promised equality
and we haven't delivered it there's
still poverty there's inequality and all
of this therefore you're either a
hypocrite or America's either
hypocritical or to failure right and
there's a right-wing critique of that
which says equality is sort of obviously
not true only a delusional fool could
believe in it therefore America's flawed
from the beginning or the corollary to
that is ah they didn't really mean equal
they just met rights of Englishmen or
some qualified or or you want a downer
rating so much because it's such a
dangerous idea yeah and to which I'd say
look both of you guys both sides on that
debate are wrong right equality has a
very specific meaning for the founders
it doesn't mean levelling it doesn't
mean that denial differences and talent
and virtue and so on among individual
human beings it knows that those things
are going to be unevenly distributed
across a population it also knows that a
regime that secures equal natural rights
will result in natural inequality as
differences in talent are able to
acquire more or less and rise to a
greater or lesser degree it knows that
so we have to get equality right if
we're going to understand the founding
and understand this solution properly
any social compact and hence any
political community is inherently
particular yes
so sinks been universals in particulars
a universal is a well in politics a
universal is a law or a principle that
applies to all at least in theory but it
doesn't necessarily mean it can be
applied to all in practice so the most
highfalutin
political regime ever conceived by the
human mind is the city and speech of
Plato's Republic right but it makes a
distinction between citizen and non
citizen it says there's going to be a
border and there's going to be I'm sorry
to be blunt but this is the Greek term
there's gonna be friends and there's
gonna be enemies so be another criticism
again you get this from the left in the
right
same metaphysical basis but for a
different outcome the left will say if
you're serious about your principles
then you can't have any borders and this
has to apply to everybody and you know
everybody should be able to do that all
is universal and the right would say
well if you're serious about your
principles you then you're a hypocrite
if you establish any kind of border or
us to have a social compact which means
you're not really serious about your
principles and you admit the fact that
all human societies particular and based
on rights right and a tradition and the
universal princess see point one we
didn't really mean it yeah we didn't
really mean it
more or maybe normal but sometimes some
people on the right to our right I would
say say it as they didn't really mean it
or sometimes they say they meant it they
were just idiots they didn't really know
we didn't realize how dumb they were and
how bad this principle wasn't so
America's flawed from the beginning the
form must fit the matter yeah I mean
this is one of the more tricky ones to
talk about he gets people upset but you
know the founders were pretty blunt
about this point in their time they said
look we're establishing a republic here
because we think it's going to work in
the peculiar context right people
refiners all right and think back to
that I mean this is a people that had
been essentially self-governing for more
than 150 years you didn't get daily
social media cues from London every day
saying do this do that you could even
have a telegraph sailing packets would
come every once in a while you'd have
some instructions at 9:00 neglect you'd
send a governor over a Governor General
over they would try to do their best to
rule you but they were a tenuous contact
I know from hard experience the American
people had to learn how to be
self-governing over the course of well
over a century they had to fight a war
oh not alone they had provide support
but almost by themselves and so they
were the French and remember that yeah
and remember heritage you want to go so
far the Americans are looking at a
European continent in which Liberty is
far from the norm right in which to the
extent that it exists I mean Federalist
one through six is it sort of I find it
I love it it's interesting to me but you
know I am a doom I'm a gloomy sort of
person
it's dreary and it says they look at it
and they you know they talk about the
experience of Liberty on the European
continent in their time and over the
past couple of hundred years and they
say all of that suggests that we're
going to fail but nobody's been able to
get this right since the ancient world
so if even the most civilized countries
in the world and you know such as France
the most at their time most civilize and
advanced countries in the world they
don't the the founders think they're not
practicing liberty nor could they they
they certainly don't think that
let me put it this way Tom Payne you
know the famous comment in common sense
we talked about how you know despotism
had once revolved from east to west now
the principles of liberty with the same
rapidity are evolving from us to east
was that was not a widespread sentiment
among the founders that was Payne's sort
of vainglorious self assertion I think
most of them would have said to Paine
listen we appreciate your enthusiasm in
the particular case but the idea that
this notion is just going to sweep the
world and everything is going to be
governed according to republican
principles within a couple of decades is
a fantasy right right and that's a
principle going back to what you start
with Aristotle yeah you look at where
you're at and then ask clearly has a
lots of implications for how we look at
the world today and right well I mean it
certainly helps explain yes the failure
of the Iraq war right and the threat
here of that that battle that whole
project Republican government requires a
measure of commonality and customs
habits and opinions yes I think this is
sort of unquestionable I don't think the
founders would have disagreed with that
at all I don't League Abraham Lincoln
would have disagreed with that it's I
think that something on which Hamilton
and Jefferson who disagreed almost of
everything would agree on that
yeah well heartedly but we've tended to
forget it in our time or if not forget
it we can angry at people who asserted
and you know we shout at them for saying
you're a bad person
for bringing that out but look America I
got into this I went to I went and gave
a talk at Princeton last week Wednesday
and survived
I survived fine but the the the among
the hostile questions people thought
well I've got you now one of them was
you know well you're worried about you
worried about precisely that question
and I was talking about the the talk was
about nationalism and why it's
reasserting itself in Europe and to a
lesser extent in America and brought up
some thought like that and I said look I
guess the question was well what's the
difference between the American
nationalist experience in the European
nationalist experience I said well
there's a commonality and then there and
then there are differences one of the
differences is that the American nation
has been better I think I think there's
actually not really arguable than any
nation in the history of the world at
taking peoples from various diff
traditions backgrounds cultures
languages and so on and assimilating
them and making them American and making
them small our Republican it has been
better than that than any than any
country I know of ever in any
circumstance doesn't mean its capacity
is it's completely unlimited I think we
found the limit of it a while ago
and right now we're struggling with it I
don't know that we found a permanent
limit but we certainly found a limit
that we're bumping up against now we're
struggling with it and a candidate like
Donald Trump comes along and says this
is an issue when we need to prioritize
the needs of our current citizens and he
shouted at partly five people hey one of
the things like I didn't maybe point out
as vividly or as bluntly as I could have
and I kind of wish I had now is how the
left really contradicts itself on this
point on the one hand the left really
sometimes you just don't tell us what
you think the left really hates the
founding principles you know dead white
males and so on and just wants to trash
them left well okay so let's let's let's
go in but up but on the other hand they
they will say they will defend kind of
an undefended border and right and
highly immigration levels on a kind of
argument that they derive from what they
think are the founding principle so so
let's let's go into the then the second
part of the book here and spend a little
time on this you have several sections
that go into kind of this shift towards
a more radical liberalism but you you do
it through various sections that lay out
some historical liberalism and then it's
changes especially as you go into post
60s leftism right so before we get lay
that out I'm the the section following
scope and limits is called American
attacks on the front of American
solution right and it lays out sort of
three primarily American criticisms of
what the founders in Lincoln and his
heirs were trying to do I would say up
through that section right all of us
meaning us we and our friends so
asougi Elmer's some others in this room
if if if you guys find anything to
disagree with in those first five
sections I blew you I blew it
you should agree with all of that and it
starts to become more more me in my you
know glue meanest and hysterical despair
after that and then you're free to
disagree with all that in God's just
Anton going crazy so the American
attacks in the American solution it
begins with capital P progressivism
how they went after the Constitution and
the constitutional order root and branch
actually no we have the pre so wore you
to go actually sorry you're right it
doesn't go that's the second that's the
second way of the the first wave is the
pre Civil War wave which has to attack
the principles of the Declaration for
obvious reasons and comes up with the
theory of right introduces group right
which becomes dormant and then picked up
later so we move then to capital P
progressivism right which is the second
wave which attacks the founding kind of
on the basis of science and expertise we
went into the second already no count of
human nature right when Marini was here
right this is something I learned from
him more than for me one I would the
other person I would name was RJ priest
Rito is also a professor at Hillsdale
and the Dean of the Graduate School and
the third wave is what I call post 1960s
liberalism and it's a kind of
amalgamation of Rawls John Rawls wrote a
book a famous book I don't recommend
reading it it's really hard to read but
it's out there and it's influential
called a theory of justice 1971 right
and sort of new left radicalism these
emerge at the same time but they're
they're on different tracks but
eventually they and when they kind of
come to it at odds with each other at
some point they are but they they are
reconciled but on new left terms right
every to every time there's a
contradiction or tension between the two
Rawls always has to defer and give way
it never works the other way having said
that this is modern low the left isms
theories of justice mmm Rawls is a
theory of justice the other is a social
justice yeah
social justice is I think just to kind
of pop culture term for the merge of
Rawls and the new left I mean the new
left look part of my that's gonna say
intellectual I don't know how
intellectual it is but anyway part of my
back grew up in Northern California
amongst a bunch of hippies weirdos
leftists and crazy people and I went to
Berkeley which is filled with the same
type of people my hometown is Santa Cruz
which is at the same time everything you
know I've known as that kind of people
and a very influential book on me I
think I read in 1988
was destructive generation by call at
Peter Collier and David Horowitz and
those guys were to really heart like not
liberals me these were hard radicals
hanging around with people you know
bombing police stations and killing cops
and that kind of thing
crazy radicals and who then had second
thoughts later and said gee maybe we
were involved in evil and should repent
and they did repent that good for them
and they wrote a great book about not
just all the stuff that they personally
saw but that kind of encapsulated that
whole ethos a lot of it focused on
Northern California haunts that I was
familiar with and that had a real impact
on me and it's kind of stayed with me
over the years maybe because it was near
so when I see the left the more I see
the left going crazy right they and a
recent years it like it reminds me of
those echoes from my childhood and from
that book and that kind of thing that
that I don't think when the New Left
started doing what it was doing it
really had a theory I think it was just
right right just angry you know that's
where I was just kind of yeah good gonna
go I mean there's there's something
about the the you know left in its
current forms it's not merely kind of a
spinning out of the emptiness of the
progresses right and it progresses but
in hindsight had some really bad ideas
they found some roots but the new life
seems really different both
intellectually and it's more what it's
actually doing it's it's nihilistic for
lack of a better term except I mean a
real nihilist would say well I'm now a
stick because you remember our old
teacher Harry new right old we had a
teacher who called himself a nihilist
you mean he went to work every day he
lived to be like 95 how are you doing at
a very FT 5050 yeah he lived a very
orderly life and I remember I asked him
I thought I thought I was very clever I
was probably out 25 nice professor
Newman at your yeah I know I know now
that you're a fraud and hypocrite so why
would you say that I said because you
always say you're a nihilist but you
know I see you go and you buy your lunch
at the same place every day you go to
campus you always show up for work on
time you never miss a day you'll it's
totally orderly life you pay your
mortgage you do this like I'm that's not
a nihilist your bourgeois you don't get
it at all so why don't I get you said
nihilist means there is nothing I can I
could choose to live any way I want
is how I want to live I was like yeah
you got so it says it but but they're
not Annihilus in the sense they're empty
yeah they're not nonsense if they're
good Nile is Nile estate realize there's
nothing and we're going to take over but
they don't actually I used to believe
that they don't believe there's nothing
I they're not moral relativists I used
to think that and I don't anymore they
have a theory of justice and this is
really kind of the most radical part of
the book I don't think it's inaccurate
but it is kind of radical I really do
think they're motivated by a desire the
nice way to put it would be redress mhm
the not nice way to put it would be
revenge they think that the entire
ledger of human affairs is a sort of one
of victim and victimizer sinned and
sinned against they think that this is
hereditary they think that the purpose
of justice is to even out the ledger and
they're going to do it and I think that
that is you know I I wrote this before
the Cavanaugh hearing I wrote this
before a lot of the craziness that we've
seen go on in the last say six months I
wrote this before no fewer than four
presidential candidates came out and
said that there for reparations and it
seems to all be going in the direction
that I feared it would right right
so you can in your ending you talk about
a fundamental choice we still face in
right that the most sinister feature of
the post six 1960s leftism the one that
feeds all the others is the spiritual
sickness the self-loathing an
existential despair with which it has
infected the formerly confident
incapable West yes tell us about that
some and then and then we'll open up to
questions I think that they that the
left has managed based on what I was
talking about a moment ago their their
insistence on seeing all of justice and
injustice as a kind of historical ledger
you either belong to an oppressor group
or you belong to a victim group and it
doesn't matter if you personally never
repressed anybody or you personally will
that we're never oppressed although they
will they well they will deny that they
will say well what do you mean I mean
you say I was never oppressed
I could say well yeah you've never you
know suffered X or Y or Z this is why
they have to come up right concepts like
privilege and you know institutional I
remember so another one of my great
heroes is Tom Wolfe who died no last
year May of last year and he told a
story about being on a panel I think it
was at Princeton but anyway at some
elite university in the 60s and the
phrase he used was the great adjective
catch up which I'll explain briefly so
it's on this panel and it's three like
far leftists you know I don't mark you I
forgot who Mark Hughes I think was one
of them and he and and they all give
this talk about how everything is going
down the tubes and we're all about to
die and Wolfe finally just loses it and
says oh Michael Harrington was one of
them
you know I don't understand what you're
talking about we're in the middle of a
happiness explosion so he this is like
67 or 68 now it sounds like these are
troubled times right but actually the
experience of being alive then was
you're stood in the middle of this giant
economic boom that barely stops in the
end of the first second world war
you're you know people have freedom that
they haven't had pretty much ever in the
history of the world and they're using
it which is Wolfe dedicated his career a
part of his career to describing their
using that freedom to just invent kind
of new life styles and new forms all
kinds of kooky ways to enjoy themselves
and the great adjective we'll catch up
is you know when people say well you
know Michael Harrington talks about
poverty you know an economist could
easily say well we're looking at the
numbers and actually it's people really
are much less impoverished than they've
basically ever been since human being
ever the Garden of Eden right so well we
have to add an edge to it well we're
talking about relative poverty you know
and so for every kind of pathology they
wanted to name it and it manifested
gotten better they would come up with
some epicycle theory to say well yeah it
kind of looks that way but in fact it's
really bad because of our left does that
too well you can't you know you could
find a person and you'd say well you
haven't been impressed in this way or
this way or this way or all the concrete
way is that I can think of where
oppression really manifests itself but
they still want to say they're impressed
so they come up with some theory about
how in fact despite the fact that I'm a
tenured professor in an Ivy League
university and
$200,000 a year and I'm on the lecture
circuit all is I'm still oppressed
because of you know all this nonsense
that we hear right um
so much for the leave us alone coalition
and the but the point is getting back to
you the question you asked specifically
they've gotten everybody else to buy
right we buy it and even if we don't
really believe it we pretend like we do
because we don't wanna get yelled at so
when you hear somebody who's so odd like
I mean I'm sorry like Jesse Smollett
make a lot of money you're on a hit TV
show you know your celebrity in so many
ways like right in what way are you
added any kind of a disadvantage in
American society in 2019 none that I can
really think of
he might say well I'm because I'm a
minority and because I'm gay and I'm
just like what was the last time
American society really actively
discriminated against anybody for either
one of those categories as opposed to
the elite culture celebrating that it's
been a while right but he still wants to
say I'm impressed I'm a victim somehow
and I think there are a whole bunch of
people I know I'm willing to raise my
hand and say it I find that preposterous
there's a lot of other people who just
believe it that's what I mean by the
lack of confidence and there's a whole
lot of other people who kind of find it
preposterous but knowing that if I raise
my hand and say I find that preposterous
the hands gonna come off so I'm writing
a go right right and they'll go back in
there yeah little communities let's take
some questions
right back here
yeah wait for the microphone please if
you would yeah wait for the microphone
okay
what you've identified is the new left
is intersectional progressivism as first
postulated by bell hooks I thought that
this was a 2019 update of the flight
93's a and I just want to prep my
question with the following your and
stick to a question yes oh yes without a
doubt the biggest change since 2016 is
the mass t platforming of those who
oppose the intersectional left you
identified as this sort of Rawls new
left so not just on Twitter Facebook
YouTube reddit etc but PayPal stripe
Airbnb YouTube lifts you name it we are
in these sort of great platform wars
your own essay was published with under
a pseudonym and
that is the principle mode of
publication for many on social media who
fear for their own yeah names so what is
your proposal for increasing the
distribution channels for your ideas
given that the principle changed since
2016 is the dramatic cuts to
distribution of anything against the
intersection of left I wish I had a
proposal I don't I you know I agree it's
a problem I support and try to help in
every way I can all the people fighting
that problem you know my own you've got
a job yeah who I I do I do now your job
security I guess when I think about
those kinds of things my solutions tend
toward the radical they may be
impractical or but you know take a
hammer to it like I I actually there's
almost nothing about Elizabeth Warren
that I'm particularly in love with her
support but when she says break up the
big three tech firms
I almost vote for her just on that alone
I don't see what good it does to free
thought free expression to have just you
know to have 93% of the book market and
control of Amazon and to have you know
the overwhelming amount of public
discourse and control of Facebook
Twitter and Google I just I I think
that's not what the founders had in mind
and it's not good for the human mind
it's not good for civilization and you
know if Teddy Roosevelt were around if
some of the trust Buster's were around
from the turn of the last century I
think they'd be wondering what's taking
us so long right here wait for the words
Mike carrier oh that's a little right
there first go ahead good question uh
after you said you'd first heard a
succinct statement of Donald Trump's
position on free trade you said you went
back at night you went back to your
place and you took all night reading
three different publications what were
those again they weren't I didn't read
them all because they're long but I read
sections of Adam Smith Adam Smith so but
the wealth nations not Theory of Moral
Sentiments
Ricardo's book I can't remember what the
title of it is but it's the one on
comparative advantage and hairstyles
politics okay go ahead I've see if I can
if you can clarify this
certainly the people back in the period
of framing a constitution and such were
under the influence of a lot of you know
classical authors Plutarch just to take
one and then within those sort of
moralistic writings coming from the
classical world there was this definite
line of thinking that witness when a
society becomes corrupt right you know
right through the fabric of the society
then basically the country that you're
talking about is going to go downhill
it's whatever power it has its gonna
lose there actually was a very
influential 19th century figure who
questioned that he said actually that's
makes great moral reading edification
but you can show many examples of
totally corrupt societies which at least
as far as the country went didn't lose
its power you know may have been
horrible for the people living there so
so where do you come down in this
because you certainly point out the
corruption so does that mean we're gonna
go down I mean no flying theory society
I make no predictions but I'm a believer
in the classical conception of the cycle
of regimes it seems to me to be pretty
airtight in theory and borne out by a
historical experience I'm working on a
major I don't know if it's major but
anyway it'll be long the study of
Montesquieu's considerations on the
greatness of the Romans in their decline
which I call my subtitle is a case study
on the cycle of regimes I think that's
what that book essentially is so that's
a law of nature that will never be
repealed where the United States may or
may not be in the cycle is something we
can all think about in question I do
think we shouldn't be complacent right
now I don't think we should just you
know I love Ronald Reagan in so many
ways I think it would be naive at this
moment to take for granted one of his
favorite catch phrases that you know
America's best days are yet to be that's
us not to say that they necessarily
aren't but if they're going to be we're
going to need to make them be we can't
just sit back and and hope or assume
that that's going to happen
I picked this guy earlier back right
here in the middle Brandon all right
higher high yes so what do you think is
going to happen with a lot of the
nevertrump right people like maxima bill
kristol do you think after the next
election well I think it's the real
antitrump I think it's generous and
inaccurate to call them right so let's
just say the never Trump former right or
the never Trump whatever's and so the
people like butwho I mean give a boot
some actually was a friend of mine once
we both went to college we got we
started in the same year he's from
California anyway we're not anymore
that's more him than me
but I would say mutual now I think you
know somebody like crystal in the
restroom they think they're the writer
they like to call themselves the right
boot is more honest I give him credit in
being more honest and saying I'm just
broken with the right and now I'm a
Democrat and I'm on the left
I think crystal and that whole crowds
pose that they're still on the right is
preposterous and unsustainable and won't
last so if you're asking what I think
will happen I think they are and again
I'm gonna have to be a little mean but
accurate at least it'll get the point
across I think they're kind of minstrels
for the anti-trump mainstream media and
useful as long as Trump is around and as
soon as Trump is gone all their funding
and relevance that's gonna dry up and
blow away so so is it that the I mean
that that's this Trump kind of pulls
back the curtain on conservatism and it
turned out there's this divide between
conservatives who don't quite know what
to make of it and can't adjust which
includes a lot of the think tanks but
then some of these ones that become very
deeply anti Trump but clearly there was
something that he dated Trump to some
extent that drew it out of them I mean
yeah I mean crystal said something a
long time ago I forgot when I mean I'd
have to look it up but he said something
like this was the guy who wrote the
famous article about national greatness
right Bill Kristol after all right with
David Brooks was co-author right who
just came out for reparations last
Friday
he said something a while ago I don't
remember how long ago but I think it was
definitely pre Trump he said well look
if I had to prioritize between all the
domestic things that I've wanted to see
done over the years you know a balanced
budget of curtailing him this than the
other thing and war I'd picked the war
every time
if you want a simple explanation it's
probably that and Trump versus Trump has
been less of a threat to their
aggressive foreign policy than I think a
lot of people thought were feared I will
put that only in the set in this
following sense
I don't think Trump ran as an
isolationist you know I but I think a
lot of people who voted for him and
thought the air that I wanted to hear
that the rhetoric of and so every time
he does something a bit aggressive on
the world stage they feel let down and
betray but how do you explain to take
two magazines for example the direction
of the Weekly Standard and its demise
National Review on the hand which are
the ones that that published the never
Trump cover story they saw of critics
but they've adjusted to a large extent
comparatively well look I I know
something I'm not maybe enough for
everything I know something about what
actually happened in the Weekly Standard
is too simplistic to say they just went
away because of Trump all kinds of
internal fair enough but I mean in fact
they were publishing some of they were
publishing some really good very good
Biel but but some interesting pro-trump
perspectives all the way till the end
Fred Barnes they never tried to rain and
they let him do what he wanted to do and
he was always setting aside the
magazine's in particular for some reason
there was some of the critics of Trump
in the election hmm who were very strong
critics and not not merely he wasn't my
first choice but they were opposed to
him post-election have prudentially or
practically nothing is he's deliver
haven't he's delivered a lot of
conservative but it tells us something
about how they think about how about the
conservatives themselves yeah right look
as for you know I think if some people
just you know if if you always wanted
good you know judges the Supreme Court
justices and think about all other
things in the traditional Republican
agenda that he's actually been able to
deliver on so that's gonna mollify a lot
of people I think the radicalization of
the left
probably mollify Zoar scares a lot of
people I think the Brett Kavanaugh
experience was awake I hope it was a
wake-up call for a lot of people I mean
I knew I knew Brett Kavanaugh I worked
with him for four years and I was in the
Bush White House and I liked the guy and
you know the last thing I was thinking I
am what do you think of when you think
of Brett Kavanaugh
you know sort of
drunken Viking serial rapist yeah that's
the first thing I think of when I think
of breaking it was so completely
preposterous that if you're paying
attention at all you'd think wow these
people will stop at nothing and they
want to steamroll totally innocent human
beings for political ends
and it probably wakes you up to a little
of that now there's a Great Divide where
a lot of conservatives who said they
were always for you know strict
constructionists originalist judges who
are going to interpret the Constitution
you know anybody who said that they were
for that for the past 30 years who
couldn't stand up for Brett Kavanaugh in
the face of obvious calumny I just you
know right then you're just written off
you're not you're not conservative
you're not a friend you're not an ally
you're just you are whatever you are but
you're none of those things and I don't
think I can even take you seriously as
someone who's even trying to be
consistent with their past philosophic
positions maybe that goes back to your
point about conservative becoming so
doctrinal it's incapable of making
practical actually though it's not I you
be better if they were I mean they would
have been better have they just been
doctrinal on that question you could say
well I've doctrinal without
constitutional interpretation this is a
good man who's gonna do a good job of
constitutional interpretation the
accusation seems pretty flimsy and even
if it's not you know you have to be
guilty until proven in so they didn't
they couldn't even do that they just
thought well the wind is blowing this
way and from the left and so on that's
where I'm going
thank you for coming out tonight and
addressing all these important issues so
in regards to your thoughts on the Mir
versus the good life might there be a
point where the real per capita wealth
or income of society could reach a point
that it's morally merit able to provide
every individual with the resources
necessary to achieve the mere life that
then they could have that mere life
without laboring and therefore all their
labor could be in pursuit of the good
life and why or why not
would that be so sounds like the Andrew
yang platform which is sweeping the
nation
well sweeping parts of the nation it
reminds me of kind of a paul light in
the sense that this is seems like a guy
who's gonna have a small but extremely
devoted following right up until the end
i don't stone
it's gonna win him anything except that
small but Toyota following I guess what
concerns me about that is you know from
many books that I've read ancient and
current right the centrality of work to
a sense of self-worth to a sense of
purpose to a sense of being is so
important that if you provide and if you
provide mere life with no strings what
are you doing to the soul and to the
sense of initiative that the soul
requires to you know for lack of better
term kind of get out of bed in the
morning and in a way you're almost
defeating the purpose because once the
ends of mere life are provided
externally the life becomes can become
at least for a lot of people all about
mere life and just the satisfaction of
wants and desires you're never looking
to anything higher so I would worry a
lot this is basically the root of my
opposition to what do they call it
guaranteed minimum income GMI right
right but Charles Maurey kind of had an
idea about that Charles when he wrote
that book in 2009 I long ago maybe
earlier than that and it member troys
right for the welfare state charles
murray was a proposal was a grand
bargain we guarantee a minimum income
but your side over bunches we have to
get rid of the entire welfare state not
just the transfer payments but also all
the bureaucracies and all the jobs and
the gigantic apparatus you know would
that be worth doing maybe I still I
still worry about what that does to the
human soul and I think that's that would
probably want to be one of those grand
failed experiments that we would come to
really regret right let's take right
here with one last question and then do
you think that trumpism so to speak is a
blip or do you think it's a change in
conservative orthodoxy as a thing
presumably future presidential
candidates won't be quite as loud and
over don't overcome the megaphone so to
speak it's not a blip whether it can you
know it's it's it's it's weaker
politically in terms of its number of
adherents and certainly in terms of its
predominance or visibility in the
culture
right and so it's got its stacked up
against a whole bunch of disadvantages
but it's not a blip in the sense that we
can go back to old republicanism old
conservatism if trumpism turns out to
not be viable I think what that means
I'm sorry to say it's just that the left
is just gonna win forever or until as
long as they can sustain what they're
doing however long that is in 40 years
as in 50 years is it a hundred years if
there's going to be a viable alternative
to the sort of financial social media
managerial left that we have now it will
be trumpism or something like it it's
not going to be traditional conservatism
as we knew it but where do we go from
here though I mean Trump when one might
say is a disrupting figure but what does
it need to be followed by to keep it
success going well it would need to be
followed by a party that is that's
basically focused on prioritizing the
needs of American citizens first which
means getting this border secured doing
trade deal redressing trade imbalances
and doing trade deals to favor American
workers and reorienting our foreign
policy along those lines if the party or
another party I mean the Republican
Party can't get its act together then
you know a party's die i I'd be sort of
sad to see the party go but I mean how
many was Abraham Lincoln sad to see the
Whig party go you know maybe not if it
can't do what it's supposed to do
anymore then maybe you should go I'd
like to see it get its act together and
do it it should be done but if it can
I'm not gonna mourn it just because it's
the Republican Party and I used to vote
for it if the at the alternative is to
just be the same old Republican Party
with the same old agenda and just keep
losing forever then you know other
people can cry over it I won't so the
one thing you didn't you didn't point
out that they should do is is read
things written by Michael Anton I just
assume they're already because if I
think the book is after the flight 93
election thank you for joining us thank
you my class
[Applause]